you get a lot of tattoos yeah I got a
handful do they ever just attach to
artists ever try and talk you out of it
no which they should yeah I just so like
Nick Swardson like yeah like what do you
want yeah I'm like I don't know I got a
spider on my face yeah I could get
whatever I wanted there's like no red
flight or just like sports into its do
it did you once get a tattoo on a boat I
got on a cruise ship yeah I right enjoy
that's not where I would get attacked if
I first of all I don't have a tattoo and
I'm not getting a tattoo but if I was
gonna get a tattoo I wouldn't want to
get it on a boat do you want to go to
Vegas Conan yeah so I did I perform on a
cruise ship it was with a band train and
I was the comedian and I was boarding
the cruise ship and I ran into tattoo
artist he goes hey I'm tattooing people
on the boat if you want to tattoo a hook
you up and this was at the beginning of
the cruise and I go yeah I'm not gonna
get set to on a cruise ship and then
five days into it I'm like where's that
one guy
so Chris Kirkpatrick from insync
was also on the boat performing so we
had like brode down the whole cruise
hahaha so we got a tattoo together so
this is what we got okay let's check it
out
this is um right throgh best trip ever
part two that's half of a heart with the
other half a stick and the best part
I'm changing my mind I am getting a
tattoo there really yeah what was the
best part I'm sorry now his wife is just
like Chris's wife is just like is this
happening you have to have stories of
sure that makes it really fun
you